Yeah, but only do this in order. If he has a hack in a 3 base origin main, hackamadai
Colitima wood?
As my check status also on the existing.
Mirja al-al al-Main.
La regao de la Ul?
Yeah, I'm…
National Pipeline Integration, though.
Okay.
Oh.
And… be in…
Mishi Damae, damain neha yagatimir jaw main, abu no offfrut, abl mahmer jan main, dihaga si ois sidi. Ablan merjan main, laden nuran schwaite test kil.
Okay, got failure. Share your screen.
on a list from a Magellis Fargo, on a comment.
Lana and Abolah,
Nishi will get the details of that celebratron
May she be checkout, you install FFM peg, yanke install schwaite dependencies GitHub na
Okay, Viran Shwaitas
Okay, by the halos be completed drop of halos.
Pibawada?
Okay.
Feeling after one minute.
So, if you need all?
Rafield
So many
Oh…
Okay, fantastic. No module name de whisper.
He'll back in the system sharfai, salient.
The tari balis.
Don't me.
feled.
The man mentioned.
And file will, um…
Yeah, are you a…
El almendo.
El al-Men Brancho.
Alarming branch, the…
Michigan…
abliba.
Hello, I'm in, uh, you mean?
test for this muscle unfolder.
Okay.
or mainly, uh, cool lunch.
La Arsenal, menalal…
I will… I'll test composition. Another lesson, Chimer Jalmino.
Tested pipeline integration. Analometric pipeline, let's some amaltish, uh…
was up.
They're just lake basalena ripona se nodere namilo.
Mean, Ahmad, Ahmad Aid
Good meeting for you
Small meetings, huh?
And if that…
Anything else, me? I'm sorry for me, halali.
So, look on ahead and smoking,
The Mahal comments.
And then, come at usema.
I'm not familiarity thing, because they are a little under…
A
And I'm able to do what you think?
another guy, and… gett, check out main.
main branch.
Nice.
a business pillow, business.
Gamma…
sir.
Oh, yeah.
Hello. I'm about to look on my…
Hi, good ma'am, Alice, sorry, sorry.
business school.
Sorry,
Tajintragal ji, sir
And si hagasma tari bun, I guess
Cherry pick
Malachitan is very aware.
It's Maha Cherry Pic
30Tech?
towards the branches
Lecomic edema. Bitpick men hoon.
Sharfa
Oaxata.
Uh, now I have gotten it from scratch.
Oh
Miss.
Let's you copy one or more specific comment from one branch and apply them to another branch without merging the entire branch.
Want to be part of someone
Nothing first
Which includes the rewards, because it doesn't be usually written
You see, an amshapa, naman kanosheril child diza
After that, I'll
And group, okay?
Yeah, guys, Vikas out of the bloc.
Deadline ideally
We theorettaic school.
But the boy animado, uh,
Okay
And had the salsa
Michelanos, camelow also.
on a server mal, uh…
Bev.
So, kosimomial. Alos?
Okay, Mishana. Pipeline?
will, uh, with database schema?
Where… with AP oils.
folder migration, they'll, uh…
the database, uh, file migration.
add that MM will pipeline burden of that MMM.
Where is any route, the country, Lapi oil, postpool gets.
ul input-output.
We're about the calendar,
Okay, please.
Sorry, but then
of the kind of hesitant in.
I also come
Uh, but…
Okay.
I wonder if you file malicious and as far as Alice. We file a smud example, the EVA
the… that can affect you, that can more fruitful, uh, weapon of stuff.
I'm starting to do both examples of triggers.
and can feel the Super Base URL will key.
Okay, come on.
function.
Any other…
a little lower.
And then I will two agents, I will Savalin, mainly the crew oil.
like a transcript or planner.
thread.
hopefully I'll function with iPhone.
Matomy freeze little API.
two users.
leta tambien.
el format stage.
Okay, Mesh. Okay, help.
So maybe…
Okay.
I see.
And the script regeneration. Muhammad Nahdi
Text-to-speech
I'm gonna sell them to Model A.
Sold them to Jimin
Nice. Okay. So, by the Elsin Planet, that is ma Mustafa, scene planner lozaimona filmystaga simplanner kebir awee.
Because
Their contract de la camabota al group.
Okay.
Nish. Sorry, minil can be a transcription, Usama
Since the massage whisper
Estagland toes per exo
Okay.
Hello.
I mean
Balash local affili API key, il kitamin OpenAI
fish locally.
For the massage.
I keep telling them.
5. El Umar Khalid
There you are.
Yeah.
Hey Edhuni
as a service.
In the fruit gamma… assets, based darat description alhalamisakh.
Okay, Baba Tamil has cropping.
uh…
Zalando.
Okay, and it's a bit…
Visit the description, Lena, no banana utolo kalari surah
Oh,
I wanna… I wanna…
Mishu, okay, hello, it's less than critical.
Uh-oh.
Oh my gosh, masalam is reliable
Will energy.
All right.
Can you input a little highlight.
sa.
Dami.
Anay Zabha, our shofill outputa is a only description kasil chya. Maasurall.
That way.
Okay, Besides more.
The letter description starts out
Oh, Smish.
Okay?
Okay.
Next, hello
Hello, Armish. Nazaba.
There's another.
Okay, that group. Jason, ready, the rendering stage, okay?
Where image left to image right. Columns, okay? Invalid output.
Clausiani, our module model validation class. La 5 missing assets. Invalid word, timestamp, passal… validation colit stemia.
With a lally output, okay? But how about you for output my iron gas
Okay, wait.
Oh, oh. And he was concerned, because
And I had thought of the family.
Our green is the.
Okay.
Share screen on.
That output is in the
Okay.
Now, the Titan Chakrahi Navasha, sorry.
Okay, let me start with your scoot
We can… okay, that I'll title, ma'am. There are text Harek Shrekha online
Hello
Great.
Mike.
The tax rate will emerge at the image local for Hawaii Hotel placeholder
database.
Yeah, no, okay, let us add a placeholders
He relax
For my first son never read whole text boxes
placeholders.
Yeah, hey,
Hello, Taravis Hassani… kasa placeholder.
Duffy Texas
The Panama Canal have Generation AI complex.
I wanted to use raja
Sure, sir
Shaifa
-
Content creators will have these platforms
Code complex
Paid.
And how this really can be critical.
Okay, Mr. Halha.
Okay.
In business, Hayato, nasi, in operation. Makota de flus.
However, morro.
And the ibachini.
Okay, pricing okay with me?
From Hagar
video generation.
Our composition.
over-engineered
When I grew up with
Now, over-engineered the Rakuten had me extremely costi.
Kaza afka.
Sufika Rabi is open, yeah.
Okay, but… okay, okay. I need an API key, and I ko takat us
Oh, there is satisfaction. The animation engine. The whole list
I think. Jason Borde rendering stage.
Michelle?
Okay, I got it, I got it.
Taharak
At least, man.
More complex calculations with shaft haga generated salam.
No, I know
Then here, amateurs two columnsdon.
Okay, okay. Hmm.
Hmm.
I know, because at least Masal and hack. Shaifa dihy.
Yenny, just the background, wahanafi Sprints
Well, I do,
And I, there was enough
I'm sophisticated.
Okay
Explore, explore! Explore. And our ethic, ibadi, na portumatami smalencia, die, over, over
Basang kuta virtual internship, nanakut physical anakut internship spin
Instagram style. Like, in
Hmm.
VPN.
ok.
Okay, I'll put in Hadiq Shifti.
Lofi haga asan minkita tutlaw
Okay.
Let's print the video
Yani anomugnaadir.
Okay, Anabargu, at least Hauli
Notice the lady
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Mmm, okay, Ms. No, Ms. Image lefto, image right, okay, then
icons.
Amade
Oh, and how little fruit, halali.
Hi, Slavasi, shakyamal isse.
Okay.
Okay?
Okay, about protective?
That's a group also,
Okay, no… screenshot, le frame it as print.
Okay, okay, okay, noted.
Okay, hello. Hello, everyone.
Do you need help?
LA
Double stations
The no one
And Sharfament is very high, I will wear.
Team Shawa
Hey, Mustafa
You, sir.
rendering.
So, Khaldeen Amazon, I will Sprints, honey tilt
I'm in my list.
Mil Vikal
Almost.
Are you a quit the bowlin to integrate
Ahmade script nichtmud.
The agent…
Miss.
Oh, and how…yani, no, itala a script
And at the moment. External absence,
I'm gonna miss.
American School.
Hmm, you need to…
Oh, man.
Can I have some Sprints have?
Someone missed.
group of meetings.
Anacle Pipeline.
Yeah, yeah.
La la, intra-integration, lah, me laksum, crew AI
And the cool functions, it functions.
So, I mean, I…
It's called Steam Planner. The Steam Planner Lego webinar el Agentic confegro creoi. Atla bella Agent Messen
Oh,
back here, haven't I?
Amendment.
Mixed.
Okay? Altas.
One is a full Sprints planning, but so I guess yan isaim all, anepti in integr.
Well, I think kil Sprintelgayam shatkun task.kas.
Now, Ms. Browns, Ms. Branson!
Many of the sandals
On May 9th
I mean, why
Hmm.
Okay.
May she?
Listen, listen, listen, Sebastian, I'll put Bokkrawai in… if we can
Have this any alternative notes?
Hiba Yousef,
Amal pushle haktu
You can have the chak in the bus
uh…
Or of ad branch.
But, uh, they're not correct.
Sir, I heard comments…
Yousef animation. However
Oh, that's a useful animation.
Oh, no, Fruda
Chuck Sarah.
Yes, sir. Hello, Salvin and Shufan outside.
To resolve our new version coming
Machine
Hello!
For sure.
I will tell Eva
Wow, I don't they
Uh, yeah,
local alar jaget el…
el commentedania?
Because I meant to add?
Hello, Columbus.
Kolo Ipulsatpul lost.
Hello, hello
Uh, migration, I hope.
Hola.
Hello, Columba.
the schema.
would test the alignment mode.
Hello, okay. Hello
Hello, Arthur.
Hello, I learned to machine breath kway seniors. Numong kundang project table maidos.
Also, then
LA?
Thomas toilet
What is the name?
No, Dr.
I'm sorry, Malib
Dr. Project.
Well, Boxadava and Portugal
containers about pedals, huh?
You can container one on a day.
And I hope Kubernets were due.
The… hota.
Okay, okay, about whole kueh
Okay
Eliza number.
Only
Is the foil tiny, any real composition you're composting will test composition of Slovenia.
Please hold as any of the collapses.
an SDG image.
SVG MH. SVGMSG slide naf sa?
And the whole composition compost scene will test composition. Buto SVG preview renderer.
Okay, any chance to go away il content.
Results
Okay, so Elva.
In Nova, the…
Ms. Muskela, tub. It's okay, alos.
Okay.
Who can integrate to Vadin, or whatever the scene
It was very hard to, okay, that was okay.
Okay.
Documentation? Aham mahaga bag, kil nahada sha gal fa- u document in yaml documentation, el branch elfied.
Okay? Documentation, little functionality
I melted documentation better.
I'm about to pin.
Let me go branch
messy.
Okay, Ms. Toy, miss.
Okay, and I is a documentation, the whole feature, as long as in the machine will ever call us
Hamil, well documentation will mean
Linman Branch.
What happened to lethal boy floinagas.
I mean…
Well, documentation, please, please, please, please, Ashan Hotri, elected.
Laisen.
And either documentation, little functionality will flow
Shahid functions, bhai melkasa anthore ina habat kulfunction tani is maha kasa awful function si bidasar feasturkut, oi biajamin
From a simple structure of documentation, I'll feature hyper description feature.
Pia snippets record.
Damona meluba dimba, melo ik document level documentation.
Okay?
Not only anywhere.
Our meeting recorded.
Oh.
Michelle, I think I remember, available answer.
No
Right.
You see?
-Oh
Busikido
I have another company
Well, yes, you can screen number.
the different layouts, okay?
Nice, nice.
The placehold and the image, okay?
Okay, hold on
Is that the…
Italic masalan.
Hmm.
From Hagar
Hmm, okay.
With Icon Sprints forkun tahti hamasalan ay sa bot et lions masaan kit.
I…
Another thing…
The same really outs, calculated layouts, och kanaztani isch.
Bas.
But…
May I ask.
The image left, or text rate, the image right, text left.
Hmm.
1, 2, 3, 4
Koi until lemon tufini, lama trophy template
Okay
It's on your house
You see? Atle structure.
I use it bus.
Hmm.
You know, okay
Nice.
Oh, I hired another side zone.
The calamic bomb actually. Na.
When the call function goal, function beta, and function betata with time will generate this change.
Nice, okay, okay.
Okay?
Okay.
I mean templates, sir?
Semio? Sa.
The template.
an MLS toolkit database, I…
Are you a student on the fall?
Okay, exactly the template, okay.
But since he was since the, my other placeholders
Banana
Okay?
Hmm.
Is templi
Any template.
I observe… I sent it toward the Canada.
Hmm.
data.
Shufit logarith itself.
It is a option
A option A
However, retrieval website.
Maybe, health, sir, hali mo kita tamil HTML
Masalon, HTML Hijik, oh, any… sushi, any storm, omoko econando, of course. Ynauten que latin al bihtml page.
If we are placeholders, alkaza, the aya, ahi poison hata au Bai LLM code at zero web page template mechanism.
And I'm gonna start…
i.
template. Tema retrieval manual database.
I'm looking solely.
Okay, I need another
And at the moment. And, uh, I hang out there with India at the end.
What's the whole cafeteria.
Kutamale says.
conversion rate slides
From content, and the content, and I'm just on topic
You see? They'll constant stuff.
The light charity fee.
Uh…
five templates
Yeah, I mean, how did you generate the templates?
HTML.
That is true.
Yeah,
That's kind of HTML from scratch. HTML mahi.
Hmm.
Okay, okay.
Okay?
Okay, for example
Yeah, and if…tml template
Now, some hate the point
HTML
Temp2.html.
Hansa.
HTML page, via placeholders.
Okay
Okay.
Anyway
Our Python… Python catac endommund.
Lala, I…
Mapo is nice
Hmm…
Okay
I want to introduce janana
Hold on.
I remove Kenya
our homes.
Oh
Oh, I think Napital.
Abdullah, let's abdal.
Sir, finally, the last applicable, I'll bid you. By the name, I'll bid you, bil animation tattoo, the HTML or JavaScript.
Because I had a whip three.
Okay?
And I don't start with creator.
Web3, Othijias,
AWS 3D
mess. Mesh, miss.
May is one of my hello, technology.
Hi all, Tani Manishyamar, Manish?
Barduan projects, many projects.
work free with TZ.
Asaka
And I can still struggle with that animation.
Shahi Zakeda
When Lilith Abbas became a doctor.
Yeah, an amokan amen
JS?
Missy? i.
lay out the screens of itself.
and be a…
Madam, Shai is a user, and I said MP4. Shai is a user is the third page.
Samhagar?
CloudBot 2018, uh…
Mace…
JavaScript.
Anaka developer.
el usasta la haga.
I love video.
El frontend malestrian.
funnel out a lot.html file, go as JavaScript?
Hello. Sa.
Sir, the solution
My other m before.
May you download
Sharf
Our monk and I…
befor.
HTML.
We execute the JavaScript, title animation, templates.
Okay.
submachna.
my enamel.
Mesha, what am I download, ba until PRG? Oh, now, or little PRG? I will, like, download as those MP4
Also
I will…
Okay?
Lower cloth.
Uh, uh, uh…
We all like a clothing, thinking, sorry
Wizarding…
Nice. I often think.
for him to go.
the voice of your mesharpay. Haga?
Okay then
CSS.
Okafront.
Busi, Learner A4…
In Subat National.
Lay, lay, lay, lay, lay, lay.
Okay, okay, okay.
7X Sudi, gamaya gamma voceulia, walnut.
Sprints
Ha
Hmm.
Come in?
for two steps.
The bootstrap reactor like
Hey?
Good stuff.
The visual one?
Yanni, ahua… graphics.
Yeah, I had never linked them all to website CGS.
Allosamographics.
Hmm.
I wanted to end.
Okay, Mish.
For me?
Oh.
It all had a flower sleek
Some image.
Okay.
Okay, then.
It'll be only one hour left to commit to the Ashana commit
Then, I think
Hollows.
Sister, okay.
Okay, okay, yeah.
You see? Okay, now that excited about this guy, a woman.
I'm also
Can I get aiser wickens woud, wastas katen las ser. Jaani.
Layla, this doesn't have…
10am inshallah
So, man.
Another one, I'm the experience, okay?
Juliano
So,
database burden management systems, uh, talk are there a few…
They may…
And in the Latinum Testool keto.
So, hated by animation-wise, it should be a video.
now I have the control now.
Any whatever, and about, like, any, I think.
Sprints
You cannot align with you
Temple hut
I miss, uh, effort to take care as well.
Hmm.
him in the scoop in the book.
Yeah, Mark
May.
Mehilana…
Oh, what about books
I mean…
And if you're meeting your retrospective, you may
Iowa.
got our laundry.
Either one.
Okay. Okay.
Machine?
Like, the language chain of
The website time, I will be, uh…
If you have already established already?
The gammao, uh…
good hands.
Okay.
Smitha, any
educational videos?
Hi, Vikki, hi, Vicki, Isaacie, NC Walmart, into Learner A4.
So, we're rendering stage register
Mmm…
Right.
I mean, local content, o be animated, u be render it.
Okay, the month.
Okay, okay, yeah, no.
Allison of the Shorkflow, and they fill pipeline.
So for the next step, I will stay in.
I mean, business purposes.
Okay, hello, and
Very fabulous.
May feel sick.
Sprints.
I see.
Okay
And then make it business.
Okay, miss
Okay.
So, move
Viber. Why?
Without the feedback, please.
Fine, okay
Well, Emily, Emily, this line, Emily, Bastian Sih.
I see
Okay, great boy